what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right so normally we do like valued
comics today but I am an hour and a half
away from heading to the airport and
taking off to Orlando for Wrestlemania
so because of that I have not had a
chance to read pre lewd to armor hunters
so we will bring a value back in next
week so for today we are going to do the
story of how spider-man got the Infinity
Gauntlet and it is an amazing story this
is basically kind of like a retelling of
the original Infinity Gauntlet story and
Marvel will do that in you know in more
than a few ways they've done it several
times before I mean they did that you
know when like it was a kinda like a
children's version of the story they do
this it was like what if stories were
like you know Thanos had just kept on as
eternity in the Marvel Universe and all
the destruction and havoc that was
reigned over the course of that there
have been a lot of like you know
alternate realities where the Infinity
Gauntlet story took a different path and
the reason why is because it's just so
damn popular I mean the Infinity
Gauntlet story is one of the most
popular stories that Marvel has ever
done there's a reason why the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is making a movie
called infinity war that's based on the
Infinity Gauntlet story because it just
makes good sense it's just really really
popular now what the story does like
almost all what if stories is that it
focuses on a different universe and so
things really kind of transpired
different ways in this universe Iron Man
and The Incredible Hulk and Wolverine
and Spider Man became harder they
basically became the Fantastic Four and
the reason why isn't initially given to
us instead they're all basically
fighting Kang the Conqueror which again
makes sense because of the fact that
King was such a formidable villain for
the Fantastic for themselves but again
this is just designed to be comedic in
the sense he's just kind of poking fun
and they're making you know they're
having a light-hearted discussion here I
mean Paul Tobin the way he writes this
is just as on to kind of have a good
time as one of the things I enjoyed so
much about it but what this is is
basically all these difference to be
heroes on earth at the time when Thanos
uses the Infinity Gauntlet and wipes out
half the life in the universe now this
is cool because during the original
Infinity Gauntlet story we kind of got
that to a degree but only insofar as
like how the other superheroes viewed
what was going on like Nick Fury was
like what in the heck just happened
people are just disappearing Captain
America is like what in the world is
going on I mean folks are just vanishing
left and right but what we also end up
finding out here is that for reasons
that aren't explicitly given to us that
Reed Richards Susan storm Johnny Storm
Ben Grimm and even even Ghost Rider are
all basically gone but they've
essentially been gone for quite some
time and we don't really know why there
not there anymore but in their place
came Hulk Iron Man Wolverine and
spider-man taking up the mantle now of
course much like the original Infinity
Gauntlet story silver surfer Adam
warlock and Doctor Strange come to visit
or superheroes now things transpired a
little bit differently but the gist was
still the same in the sense that Adam
warlock had a plan and that was the
basis behind us care to remember with
Adam warlock he's part and parcel to
cosmic energy he's really kind of like
the universe itself man I guess
manifested is kind of like a savior or
at least his relationship with the
universe is not like anything else so he
can still keep his mind shielded from
Thanos so long as Stannis doesn't know
he's there so when Thanos is using like
the the mind stone to read the minds of
everybody else in the universe Adam
warlock can keep his presence hidden
even then Thanos has such a high amount
of admiration and respect for Adam
warlock despite the fact of the two were
enemies that even if Thanos was given
the opportunity to read out of Morlocks
mind he probably wouldn't do it in fact
jim Starlin focused on this with regards
to the relationship between adam warlock
and Thanos when it came down to the two
of them actually investigating what what
kind of reality the other one would
render in terms of where they stand in
the cosmology and Thanos his reality was
very you know chaotic in very insane
whereas Adam wore Adam warlocks reality
was very structured very organized to
the point but they were essentially
detrimental they were basically extremes
and full probably cover that story since
YouTube has the ability to give us their
I guess they're giving us the ability to
make series now what we're going to do
because you guys probably noticed this
with injustice we're going to do is when
I guess maybe in the months leading up
to the release of infinity war we're
going to redo the Infinity Gauntlet
story that's going to be the first
series and then I guess season 2 will be
infinity war followed by the rest of the
infinity stories and we'll cover them
all like we do now where it's just one
video each week as part of the ongoing
series to give you guys on you know
there's this huge idea of what all jim
Starlin had done leading up to the
modern day when Adam warlock became the
living tribunal but what we need to
focus on here is the story this is one
of the cool things is because much like
the original Infinity Gauntlet story
Dallas is still being manipulated by
Mephisto now again remember cliff Fisto
is basically Satan more or less in the
realm of Marvel Comics over Marvel does
not take the DC approach DC takes a very
judeo-christian approach so you have
Lucifer Morningstar you have the
presence which is basically the God of
Abraham you have the different various
you know like the Seraphim you have all
these different kind of angels and
things like that and Marvel it's
not that way you don't really have like
Satan per se you really have like messes
so whoever reasons say you don't really
have a you know the God of Abraham you
have the one above all you don't really
have like Jesus you have the Living
Tribunal now historical characters like
Jesus did exist in Marvel Comics but
they're not like they are with people
looking at them in terms of religious
perspectives here in the real world
there's to say Jesus was not like the
Son of God you know in Marvel Comics but
the fact remains here that things really
play out in a very similar fashions in a
sense that none of these guys can really
go toe-to-toe with Dennis and that's
what we would expect mean they're all
pretty much kind of taken out they're
all you know basically sitting back to
earth just because of the fact that
Dennis is like look I don't have time to
worry about this I don't have time to
focus on any of this nonsense
you know we've got bigger fish to fry
now of course this ultimately leads to
them traveling back to where Thanos is
located but Adam warlock effectively has
a plan now of course Adam warlocks plan
is rented asunder with the defeat of the
various members of the of the celestial
order but then this is where the story
also begins to change around where thou
should effectively banished Mephisto in
the original Infinity Gauntlet storyline
in this one he pretty much destroys him
where he seems to be the case he
annihilates him in his entirety not only
that the reason why this happens is
because of the fact that Wolverine plays
a much different role and that's kind of
the cool thing in the original Infinity
Gauntlet story that's one of the reasons
why I'm so sad that will range not in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
addition just seeing Hugh Jackman
running around with Robert Downey jr.
and Chris Evans you know as Iron Man and
Captain America respectively which would
be amazing we won't get a chance to see
him in Infinity Ward and the Infinity
Gauntlet story the way it was originally
written by jim Starlin Wolverine was
basically just kind of like one of the
heroes who was attacking that was really
all there was to him but it was cool to
see fan OHS take you know Wolverine and
basically rendered him down to make him
someone who was virtually useless really
I mean for always wanted senses and his
healing factor and adamantium claws he
couldn't do anything against Thanos much
like anybody else while Stannis was
reeling the Infinity Gauntlet but in
this story
Wolverine is a lot more manipulative and
he's a lot more intelligent what he does
is he basically plays on what it is that
Mephisto does and who Mephisto is when
he told Stannis look man like are you
sure you really want the guy who is like
the master of temptation and and
seduction on your shoulder while you're
trying to deal with mistress death it's
basically Wolverine saying hey look
mister
not a wingman dude like he's trying to
steal the girl you're going after so
like you should probably banish him
because of you don't he's going to be
going home with her and you're going to
be sitting there at last call trying to
figure out what to do for the rest of
the night so the cool thing about this
is that with the different Celestials
cutting been defeated by Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet
what is up here is that like Hulk and
Iron Man and so on drag what they can of
one of the Celestials back to the portal
and begin experimenting on its armor and
this is when Tony Stark basically
becomes a celestial like he harnesses
the power of the Celestials and starts
using it for his own now this is
designed to basically be a distraction
that's one of the cool things here is
because Thanos is constantly keeping his
guard up now pretty Infinity Gauntlet
this is not a difficult task number the
Infinity Gauntlet grants damage the
ability to manipulate every facet of the
universe time space manipulate minds
manipulate reality all that kind of get
stuck that's the difference between the
Infinity Gauntlet and the heart of the
universe the Infinity Gauntlet allows
Santos to manipulate things you know it
allows him to basically pick up a pencil
or something like that to give it this
this sort of understandable metaphor the
heart of the universe makes standards
the pencil it makes him the power that
he's basically reeling so instead of
wielding power he is absolute power and
so from here it transitions over to
Wolverine this is why I say a Wolverine
so cool is because he starts messing
with Thanos right he's like hey look man
I've seen how mistress death looks at
you dude like I know you're trying to go
with it like I know you're trying to get
with mr. step you sit behind her in the
third grade I know you're trying to get
with her you've known ever since you
guys were a little kids and while she is
like you know a little frigid you know
while she is like not really the most
welcoming person of all time
she does make glimpses at you you know
if everybody knows that when you're
trying to get to a girl you know when
you're flirting you got to make that eye
contact you know you got a what's going
on you know you can't be creepy about it
but you got to make that eye contact you
know sure if she knows that you're
digging her that's what they don't you
know that's what what were he said like
hey man she's snatching glimpses at you
you know and she keeps kind of like
saying your name under her under her
breath and stuff like that you know it's
at least like it's all about touch I
mean what you've chosen here is it is a
physical form mistress death isn't you
know is it I guess manifest as a
physical beam it's all about touch man
you have to touch her to let you let her
know that you care have you ever touched
her before have you ever hugged her have
you ever done anything to indicate that
you have an interest in her beyond
simply saying I wish you would get with
me and so of course in the moment of
truth and I love it so much
in the moment of truth when Thanos
reaches out to touch mistress death
brain cuts his arm aha he's like sucker
it's one of the coolest things I love
that moment and this story it's one of
my favorite things ever but of course
this is basically this kind of what if
story a companion to the original
Infinity Gauntlet story when Thanos had
made himself eternity when he had
manifested basically as the
representation of the universe itself
and then nebula stole the Infinity
Gauntlet from him now
this raises some interesting questions
the kind of sidetrack here for a second
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe
because we know the Living Tribunal
exists now we know the multiverse exists
and so it makes sense with the Living
Tribunal will probably show up in the
movie I could see the first of the
infinity war movies or whatever you want
to call now the next Avengers movie I
could see it basically ending with like
Adam warlock or whoever it is you know
the the woman that appears in the next
guardians of the galaxy moving on
whoever it is it basically takes the
role of Adam warlock I could see that
person appearing and you know basically
having the cosmic entities beseeching
the Living Tribunal to intervene and let
me tribunal says no I exist to maintain
cosmic balance if eternity is not able
to maintain his position as absolute
power in the universe and Thanos was
trying to take his place finish the
natural order of things so we can get
replaced with the strong I can see that
happening now the second movie would
probably just pick up with the aftermath
like it just going to be you know the
the astral conflagration story from
Infinity Gauntlet works just like
everybody getting decimated by Thanos in
that amazing moment when Captain America
walks up to them and the two of them are
fighting and so on and so forth and you
know they try to kill thanos he's like
supremacy cannot be done I mean there's
so many great moments in that story I'm
really kind of hoping we see those in
the movie because Connolly tell you some
if you guys never read in Finnegan if
you haven't seen my videos go check them
out but if you guys have never read
Infinity Gauntlet
how that movie's going to blow your mind
like infinity war is gonna there is
anything like the comics it's gonna blow
your mind but because of the fact that
the annals had basically lost his arm
and in turn lost the gauntlet what ends
up happening here is of course
spider-man picks it up and that's a cool
thing because there's never been an
instance in the history of Marvel Comics
when Spiderman has ever wielded the
Infinity Gauntlet it's short it's only a
quick moment but all he really does is
just kind of start returning things you
know back to the way that they used to
be but the funny thing about this is
that he also has the ability to bring
back Uncle Ben if he so chose or the
very least to remake Uncle Ben the way
that he remembers
but the problem with this is that if you
were to remake Uncle Ben it wouldn't be
the same
Uncle Ben even if he were to resurrect
him the purpose behind spider-man our
guest Peter Parker becoming spider-man
would be lost because the death of Uncle
Ben is what made Peter Parker who he is
recognizing that it's his responsibility
to act even if he doesn't think he needs
to and so because of this what these
different characters essentially coming
back this story wraps up pretty quick
and the symphony Infinity Gauntlet it's
given to the Watchers the watchers keep
it under lock and key
Thanos kind of goes to being a farmer
and that kind of thing please wrap up
pretty fast and it's not a great big
huge grandiose ending but it's still
kind of cool to see spider-man wielding
the Infinity Gauntlet but if you guys
are new here to come and to explain make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the robb course if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah by the way I wanted
to answer the question that I saw in the
comments regarding the unworthy store
unworthy store story a lot of people
were asking the question why is it that
Thor's arm is black a lot of the guys
have answered that but I don't think a
lot of people saw the comments that was
basically a story where where Thor had
essentially just had his arm chopped off
and what he ended up doing was he
actually replaced it with I believe a
piece of the destroyer armor with the
arm of the destroyer armor or maybe it's
just straight through I can't remember
off the top of my head but he basically
built himself a new hand and I believe
that was in the very first story arc of
Jane Foster Thor before all-new
all-different marvel I'm pretty sure
that was the case I'm not going to swear
to that but I believe it was the first
story arc where she became Thor and it
basically was a lead-up to like the war
of realms and the return of malakut and
the frost giants and so on and so forth
um but if I'm wrong somebody feel free
to correct me I'm just kind of running
that off the top of my head just because
I'm in the middle of recording this
video I'm not gonna stop to look it up
and I will catch you all later please
[Music]
you